just because cars killed a lot of people
he didn't ban cars but they got together
a bunch of people and decided you know
in order to be allowed to sell a car it
has to have a seat belt in him
they're the analogous things that you
can start requiring a future AI systems
so that they are are safe
and uh once this have this heavy lifting
this intellectual work has been done by
experts in the field which can be done
quickly
I think it's beginning to be quite easy
to get policy makers to
to see yeah this is a good idea and it's
it's you know
for the fight for the companies to fight
maulock
they want and I I believe Sam Altman has
explicitly called for this they want The
Regulators to actually adopt it so that
their competition is going to abide buy
it too right you don't want
uh
you don't want to be enacting all these
principles then you abide by them and
then there's this one little
company that
doesn't sign on to it and then now they
can gradually overtake you then the
companies will get
be able to sleep secure knowing that
everybody is playing by the same rules
so do you think it's possible to develop
guard rails
that keep the systems from
uh from basically damaging irreparably
Humanity while still enabling sort of
the capitalist fueled competition
between companies as they develop how to
best make money with this AI you think
there's a balancing totally that's
possible absolutely I mean we've seen
that in many other sectors where you've
had the free market produce quite good
things without uh causing particular
harm
um when the guard rails are there and
they work you know
capitalism is very effective good way of
optimizing for for just getting the same
things done more efficiently it was but
it was good you know and like in
hindsight I never met anyone
even
on parties way over on the right in in
any country who think it was a bad
thinks it was a terrible idea to ban
child labor for example
yeah but it seems like this particular
technology has gotten so good so fast
become
powerful
to a degree where you could see in the
near term the ability to make a lot of
money and to put guard rails to develop
guard rails quickly in that kind of
context seems to be tricky it's not uh
similar to cars or child labor it seems
like the opportunity to make a lot of
money here very quickly is right here
yeah so again there's this cliff
on the ground you can pick up or
whatever so you want to drive there very
fast but it's not in anyone's incentive
that we go over the cliff and it's not
like everybody's in their own car all
the cars are connected together with a
chain yeah so if anyone goes over
they'll start dragging others down the
other's down too and so ultimately it's
in the selfish
interests also of the people in the
companies to to uh
slow down when the when you start seeing
the Contours of the cliff there in front
of you right and the problem is that um
even though the people who are building
the technology
and the CEOs they really get it the
shareholders and these other Market
forces they are people who don't
honestly
understand that the cliff is there they
usually don't you have to get quite into
the weeds to really appreciate how
powerful this is and how fast and a lot
of people are even still stuck again in
this idea that
intelligent in this carbon chauvinism as
I like to call that that you can only
have our level of intelligence in
humans that there's something magical
about it whereas the people in the tech
companies
we build this stuff they all realize
that intelligence is
information processing of a certain kind
and it really doesn't matter at all
whether the information is processed by
carbon atoms in neurons in brains or by
silicon atoms and some technology we
build